欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
关于优爆品提升的实战方法
接下来我们来讲解一下剩余的这些优品如何去提升
比如说平台新品的时候我们怎么样去提升
第一个就是最快的方法就是去发定向争品
这是最快的方法
第二种方法就是有些行业它是没有定向争品的
那么这个时候我们就要去看行业里面的这些新品场景里面
的产品都有哪些属性, 或者是我们店铺当前同类的产品, 是填写了哪些属性, 和用了哪些关键词, 成为新品的, 这个时候我们就可以去参考这些属性去发产品就可以了, 因为这个平台的新品它本来是, 概念就是比较模糊的, 很难用一个比较明确的指标去衡量, 所以我们在发产品的时候, 优先考虑定向真品, 然后
然后再去看哪些当季的产品, 或者是当前平台偏向的款式去发就可以了, 第二个就是国家真选品, 这个的话只要你满足国家的定向
真品的需求就可以了, 也就是你在发产品的时候要满足这些国家, 按照后台的指示去发就可以了, 不同的行业它是有差异化的, 并不是都一样, 有些行业是没有这些国家真选品的
第七个就是
行业服务利品
那么你要满足
它的一个标准就是
你要有认证的证书
而且证书数量
或者是类型
你要满足条件了之后
才会
把这个产品绑定了
这些证书之后
这个产品才能成为
行业服务利品
具体的
证书数量
以及它的证书类型
需要你自己去后台看
到时候后台会更新的
所以说你到时候关注后台
去满足他的指标就可以了
第八个就是内容竞争利品
这个也是在待定还没有更新
那么到时候我们再强解这个板块
第九个就是价格竞争利品
那么这种的话主要就是凸显价格的优势
说白了就是低价
提升商机的转化率
如果你做不了这个价格
那么你就没有必要注重这个板块
因为成为优品的局道或者是路径非常多非常多,你看这么多路径
那么你可以选择其中几种你擅长的路径去提升就可以了
并不代表说所有的类型你都要去满足
你要把自己的优势发挥出来,而且是硬性指标满足不了的
那么我们就想办法去做我们能够做的事情就可以了
那么第11个就是我们要看一下
单品基础指标要必须是达标,也就是你想要成为上面的这几种类型的优品, 那么你必须要满足下面的三个条件, 第一个就是近90天的发货率要大于等于90%, 第二个就是近90天信保退款申请率小于10%, 第三个就是商品评价分大于等于四分, 所以你的
你的单品即使数据非常非常好,如果你这三个指标都没有达成的话,那么你也是没有办法成为优品和爆品的,你这个几个指标是前品,第十一个板块就是优品有哪些权益,我们来看一下它到底有哪些权益,比如说我们从这里可以看出它的权益是比较多的,不同的类型的产品,你看这些产品
那么他对应的权益是不一样的,比如说你看他对应的新品是对应的这是这些权益, 爆品是对应的是这些权益, 国家争选品对应这些权益, 这些权益, 这些的话我们只需要后台去了解就可以了, 这里的话就不在后台去展示了, 到时候后台会更新, 你根据这些板块内容, 一个个针对性的去看后台, 以及阿里首页
首页如何展示的, 你要去把它弄懂, 把这规则搞清楚, 然后再去操作, 那么你的事情就更加简单, 那么最后一个我们要注意的一些误区, 一个产品可能符合多个品质, 也就是你的A产品可能是价格竞争利品, 也可能是爆品, 也可能是行业服务利品, 第二个就是我们一定要去提升爆品的质量排名, 不能纯靠自动车, 也
就是我们在推广爆品的时候一定要注重它的一个排名,去关注它的数据, 不然的话我们全部都是直通车,那么到后期也是很难稳定的,第三个就是爆品优品,这些等级都是动态变化的,可以升级,也可以下降,只有持续的符合条件才能够持续的成为优品或爆品,我们前面也讲了,比如说你的爆品可能需要10个订单,10个买家数才能成为
爆品如果你的90天内这个产品的订单量买家数变成了9个那么他就是不符合那么他就不是爆品他就不会是爆品那么就下降了如果你又加一个订单那么他也就够了10个订单那么他就有就会再次变为爆品所以这个情况一定要注意他是动态变化的这就是为什么我们店铺
店铺里面的优品数量, 每天, 每周, 或者是每个月, 看到的数据都是不一样的, 有时候在持续的暴跌, 有时候在增长, 这个的话就是看你
前期有没有布局好, 去用我们前面所讲的那些方法去提升它的总量, 持续的去提升它的总量, 这样按批次的去提升, 那么你的整个店铺的优品, 才会持续的稳定和增长, 那么这个就是关于
优品, 爆品提升的实战方法, 这些板块都是非常具有实操性的, 你一定要先去理解规则, 按照这个方法去操作, 那么你的店铺的优品才会更加稳定, 才会不断的提升, 这节课我们就先讲到这里, 下节课我们再见